i've seen a bit of talk about this thing
called a tpm is it trusted platform
module or something yeah that's right
the trusted platform module and that the
new version of windows may require a tpm
what is a tpm and how does it work so
yes it is the trusted platform module
and one of the things that windows 11 is
going to require
a pc to have is to have a trusted
platform module
as part of it the idea behind a trusted
platform module is a way of making
computers secure or more secure and
the best way to understand why we might
need one is to think about
how things would happen if we don't have
one in a sort of traditional
computer setup
mike's done a lot of videos looking at
various encryption algorithms and things
and one of the common factors
whatever your encryption algorithm is
let's call it inc
we've got a function and that is going
to take a key
and this might be a symmetric key might
be a public private key
thing it's going to take a key and it's
going to take
a message that we want to encrypt
and then you can go and watch any of
mike's videos pick your favorite
encryption algorithm
and he will explain it with some
wonderful diagrams some colorful colors
and some liquids he's pouring around and
things but the problem we've got
is the key we need to keep a copy of the
key on our computer system so what can
we do to keep it private
well if we have it in the computer's
memory theoretically any programming
running on
the computer could potentially access it
now normally the operating system and
the memory management unit in the cpu
will stop that happening
they will protect it but that
requires the operating system to be
working
in the way you want it to do it's
running the code you expect to be
running
and not one that's been modified by some
dodgy geezer called mike
and as well as encrypting your message
it's also sending a copy of your key
to mica i've got yourkey.com i only joke
mike doesn't do use that web address to
catch people's keys he uses a different
one so we've got a problem we need
to keep the key secure we could keep it
on the computer in memory
but it's potentially possible something
else could access it or we could write
it onto the hard disk
but if someone gains access to your hard
disk they've got the key on sean how do
you think we might keep it secret
this feels like a trap but i'm going to
say it anyway you could encrypt it well
yeah so yeah we could encrypt the key
but the problem then is that
all we've done is we've just moved the
problem we've now made the key that
we're using to sign our messages secure
but we now have to keep the key used to
decrypt
the key that we're using to encrypt our
messages secure as well so
we could do that and that is actually
what's part of the prop the tpm will do
but we still have the same problem we
have a key on our system that we need to
protect
so we could encrypt it but we're just
moving the problem upper layer
and the same is true with the software
we could say well actually we'll
encrypt or hash the version of windows
on
the system or whatever operating system
we're using and then if that when we
load it in
um we'll make sure that it matches that
hash well that's fine but now you've got
the bootloader has to be
the thing you trust because you need to
say well if someone modified the
bootloader it might not
check it properly and say yes this is
correct when actually they've just
slipped in a bit so mike gets your key
it seems to me that
something has to be trusted at some
point somewhere yeah exactly so we need
some way of
storing this so that we know the key is
accessible
but we can't get it out of the system
unless we want to get it out of the
system so this is what the trusted
platform module
on a computer effectively does it
provides a way of storing keys
so that we can use them we can do that
but in a way that means that they aren't
going to be sort of compromised by mike
or anyone else who's trying to
get access to your keys well how do we
do that what does the tpm
do to do that we talked earlier about
how one way we can protect the key
is by encrypting it we encrypt it and
then we have a form that we can store
and then when we need to use it we
decrypt it and then we get rid of the
degraded
version as soon as we finish that so
basically the trusted platform module
is a little chip which is effectively a
very small computer in its own right
it's running software that can store
keys
it can generate random numbers secure
random numbers
it provides the sort of support that you
would need in the computer system to do
cryptographic type of functions
in a secure way so let's think about our
problem of
we want to store our keys in a way so
that we
can only access them well the way that
we do that is that
in a trusted platform module we have
what's called the storage route key and
this is just a key that's been
programmed in there when the chip was
built or derived from a key that was in
the trusted platform module when the
chip was built
that is used to encrypt the keys that we
want to store
but it's stored in the trusted platform
module this separate chip
on your computer's motherboard and you
can't get the key
out of the trusted platform module you
can pass another key to the trusted
platform module and say can you
what's called wrap this key up in a way
so that i can only access it by asking
you to unwrap it and give me the key to
use
so if we want to store the key to
encrypt our message we take that key
we give it to the trusted platform
module it encrypts it
it wraps it up as it's called with the
storage root key
on the system and then we have a form
that we can store
either sometimes within the trusted
platform module or that we could
actually store it on hard disk on
inside our system because we can only
decrypt that using the trusted platform
module chip
on the motherboard for our computer and
every chip is programmed with a
different key
so that only the trusted platform module
to wrap that key
is able to unwrap it so that's basically
what the trusted platform module
is it's a chip that provides us with a
way
of doing cryptographic functions outside
the main computer system
but it's built in such a way so we can
use the keys but we can't
fetch them from the trusted platform
module
so we can take a key put it in the
trusted platform module
wrap it and then when we want to use it
we take the wrapped version give it back
to the trusted platform module
unwrap it or even potentially get the
trusted platform module
depending on what functions it
implements to do the decryption for us
we send it the data it comes back and
things the way these chips are built is
they're built so they only have
the minimal amount of functionality you
need to make it secure on them because
some bits of it you can still do
in software but you're trying to make
the bits that have to be secure
exist in this separate chip so they're
not accessible
outside the system one problem though is
you're still relying on the software
running on the system
the trusted platform module can wrap and
unwrap keys
so what's to stop me coming along or
what's the stop mic coming along with a
usb
stick sticking it in the side of your
laptop booting his favorite version of
linux
on there and then accessing your hard
disk finding the
wrapped version of the key that's on
there and asking the trusted platform
module to unwrap it
so what the trusted platform modules the
tpms also offer
is what we call ceiling a key and here
they do exactly the same thing you take
the key
you give it to the trusted platform
module and encrypts it
but as well as requiring the key that's
built into the tpm
to decrypt it it also requires what i
call the platform configuration
registers which is another part of the
trusted platform module
to have the same state in them and this
is called
sealing a key so what this basically
means is if you set these things up
right
you can only unseal the key you can only
undecrypt it effectively unseal it
when using the same trusted platform
module
and you also have the system in exactly
the same state
now how does that work well these
platform
configuration registers are registers
they're just
spaces basically inside the trusted
platform module which you can
cause to have a particular value now you
can't set them to have a specific value
but what you can do is as the system
boots up you can
change the values in there you can take
the value that's currently stored in
that register
and combine it with some value that you
give it as part of the system so for
example you could take
the value in a register and combine it
say with a hash of the
bios for example or the sort of state of
the mbr
system whatever it is that you've chosen
to do these things and then when you
come to unseal the key
as well as needing the key that's
embedded in the trusted platform module
those configuration registers you can
say this one needs to be the same this
one needs to be the same this one needs
to be the same
so you can guarantee that not only is
the system
the machine that encrypted it originally
because it's got the same key on there
but also that it's running the same
software it's the same bios version it's
the same
version of windows the hard disk perhaps
hasn't been changed in the layout
whatever it is that the system is using
to store these things and these can all
be stored in the trusted platform module
in a way that they can be stored they
can be
used but you can't read them back out
and that
set perhaps under specific circumstances
so for example if you've got a
key which you use to sign your email and
you get a new laptop
you may want to in specific cases be
able to take it out one tpm and put it
into another one and there's provision
to do that
but in general only that trusted
platform module
can access these things so it's having
something locally on your system that
you can trust and then deriving
everything else
in terms of that local thing the trusted
platform module
there's other things you can do with it
as well you can use it to
prove that this key has been signed by a
a key in a trusted platform module which
is what perhaps windows are using it for
to sort of guarantee this is running on
the machine that they sold you this copy
to run it on if you're cynical about
why they're wanting these things and
things but it also enables you to much
more guarantee that the
things are secure on your system so in a
nutshell at a very high level that's
what a trusted platform module does
on your system it's a way of trying to
secure your computer system make things
more secure by moving it off the main
computer system where you have to
eventually trust something at some point
into something that you can trust and
you can then test things along that you
can guarantee that the software you
expect is running on the system
is tpm proprietary are there different
versions of this or is this one kind of
like platform so the trusted platform
module the specification
for it was created by the trusted
computing group i think it was in the
late 90s early 2000s
and things and there's been various
versions there was certainly version 1.2
we're now at version 2.0
uh one of the major changes was allowing
support for different encryption
algorithms different hashing algorithms
so for example
tpm 1.2 the spec came out only supported
sha-1
a couple of years later shaw one was
shown that there was ways you could
compromise it
although not in a way that i think would
necessarily affect the way the tpm was
using it
and things but anyway you want to be
able to support newer better
more secure algorithms and things so
it's a specification
various different vendors produce chips
so they'll generally talk over what's
called the low pin campus the
pc bus on your computer system and you
can then refer to them
you can actually get ones that are
implemented in software and things like
that of course they're good
for simulating and testing things but
they're
software so you can change them and
they're not as secure as having in
hardware
the advantage of the hardware thing is
that because it's a dedicated chip
it's got a key embedded in it when it's
created that can't be changed and the
others are all derived from that or
wrapped or sealed with that and things
you can rely on it
cheating the keys securely even if the
system itself
gets compromised we've talked a lot
about windows
it begs the question your mac is behind
you on the desk over there
how do apple deal with this tpm isn't a
windows specific thing it's an open
specification it's supported by linux
pretty much any platform could support
it when apple
originally switched to the x86 platform
their laptops their machines did have
tpm chips
embedded on them but they didn't really
get used and then they took them off
because it's a way of saving money and
pushing the prices up but apple
basically do the same thing they
provide the same thing they do it with
their secure enclave it's got the same
sort of ideas they can program
keys into it and then they can use those
keys to wrap things but they've just
done it
in their own apple way as opposed to
using the way that everyone else
is doing it and things and that's
perfectly fine it works
some of our twitter followers will know
i recently upgraded my computer to an
amd horizon
there wasn't enough rainbows inside your
machine like rgb leds in your machines
or colorful uh lighting in my office
with my rgb beast it doesn't have a tpm
as a thing called a psp or is that
similar the tpm
provides part of the security you need
but also companies like intel and amd
are starting to
extend that so you've got intel's
trusted execution technology txt you've
got the amd psp
as you talk about and they're all trying
to make your computer more secure and
provide more ways of knowing
that the software running on your
computer is the software you expect it
to be and not mike's special brew
of the disc and the reason why you've
got that is because as these rotate
they pass between a couple of sensors
and these are a lightweight diode which
probably gives off something like
infrared light and there's no need for
it to be anything else between there's
obviously a lot of problems with it
right first of all the networks are
still not quite high resolution enough
to deal with 1080 and 4k video